hello first hello to my colleagues
who are in the who are in the room
with me and especially hello to all
of you who are watching us
today live on
cbs it's friday march 20th
as you know the
current situation means that we have had to
restrict even more access to the
buildings of the commission in general and
therefore to the press room in
particular is henceforth our
2010 meeting here in the press room therefore becomes
entirely virtual broadcast on
obs until further notice  order until
the situation improves we are
able to return to our myth of
ours usual daily press meeting
that said we will continue to
work with you under new
modalities
just allow me to
remind them  briefly
the idea is that journalists
accredited in brussels can send
questions in writing until 11 a.m. which
we group by theme and to which we are
going  as far as possible
try to answer either now in the
press room or later
bilaterally of course I ask you
to be understanding because
we too are now working
in very
unusual conditions and reaction times
are obviously sometimes longer  long
simply because
of the new circumstances in
which we have to work to
obtain the coordinates the information
but of course we will
do everything in our power to
continue to inform you as best as
we can now I have some
announcements to  do you it's
cold rumors state last night life commission
doctor and a price framework tour
britain's economic flexibility
of existence such new york road
animal'z many state street
fishing equity remains verbal business is
love takes into evidence  of
economic continuity is activated ti jean
arthuis after the fram temple  ework web increase
in till the end of the sands of time 3d
anaglyph frantz gumbs hate you find
more information
ignatieff presstalis anne of course we
can watch videos message from
executive vice president
but his opponents then yesterday the
mr dombrowski it  is the commissioner following
took part in the videoconference of the
council employment social policy health
and consumers in order to discuss
the impact of the cros ships us on employment
and the national social systems
they explained to the minister in
more depth the initiative
of  investment corona response a
wide-ranging initiative which provides 30 7
billion euros from the budget to the
health system to small and medium
-sized enterprises to workers and to
vulnerable sectors of our economies
the commission and the council
also discussed the
need for  accelerate the creation of a
European unemployment re-insurance scheme
you will find more information in
our daily news 22
representative mints said josette borel
coaching vivian balakrishnan video in
france of this casting what you see is the
nation will have cnt doubt fight covin
nineteen renault virus pandemic
she is equal to me egan is an act i would
say and have agreed  to the king and
share in from the last song youzhou
weekend respective
origins moreover a video conference of the
ministers in charge of industry will take
place this afternoon with the
executive vice president madame vesta guerre
and the commissioner monsieur breton to
discuss the  the impact of the
coronavirus crisis on the industry and the internal market
finally support week by week these are
false documents mujahideen who
know best rose foundry refinery
young people develop in formula cure via
this mode of construction poster 30 nd
sofia brain produce beautiful son
electricity and sentheim by you think you
drive angry sagbo municipal west to
specific access the stars  s genfit
fortissimo electricity from people of
life investment banking west treatment
mauritius times maureen formation in
order in youth